welcome back to las vegas now earth day
is on the 22nd of this month so i
stopped by findlay toyota to see how
they're saving your pockets
and our plan take a look
hey rocky hey john you didn't hear me
coming up
i sure didn't i knew you didn't john how
did this giant van sneak up on me like
that how's it so quiet
it's a hybrid it's a hybrid it's a
hybrid
and luckily we came up with the
technology oh you know and i say
you came up with the technology well i
could say that i could credit myself for
that but actually i'm not a
direct member of the family i'd like to
think i am but
the technology being the electric and
gas combination and
it's just unbelievable but the mileage
is astounding yeah is that your favorite
part of driving a hybrid i know you
drive one as well
it is i drive a toyota avalon and even
with current gas prices you're in a
situation where you fill a tank up for
less than forty dollars
and you can drive up to six hundred
miles what it's a umbrella
and i drive up to two hundred something
so well i'm not now i'm thinking i need
a hybrid
i think we can probably get that handle
i got brittany here oh hey girl
hi she's going to tell me how how it all
works she's going to tell you everything
because it takes some getting used to
yes it does
different yes it does because i'm
looking at this benzo right now so this
is avenza
newly redesigned got a new facelift came
back in 2020 discontinued in 2015 and
now it is absolutely gorgeous um it has
not only awesome technology inside but
it's also a fully hybrid vehicle as well
now
nice okay can i get inside a real steel
yeah hop in oh yeah okay i can see
myself riding this for sure you know
it's comfortable it's also fuel
efficient
um but yeah okay so let's talk about
just
the difference between a regular car and
a hybrid like like i said
i'm paying 40 dollars to just go 200
something miles yep
yes yeah so the major difference is
going to be the components within the
engine
so a traditional gas engine just has a
12 volt battery and
you know petrol engine that's running
everything inside with your hybrid you
have an electric motor and a gas engine
working hand in hand to give you the
most fuel efficiency
so like the lower speeds you're all
electric higher speeds you go into gas
it just keeps it nice and even for you
and i feel like this is a great car for
any age group and especially people who
are passionate about saving the planet
right it's clean energy
yeah absolutely so your carbon emissions
can be cut in half when you're driving a
hybrid vehicle in comparison to just gas
right
it's a lot more cost efficient as well
like you said so i mean you're paying
what forty dollars to go 200 miles yeah
this is 40
to go 600 miles which is absolutely
awesome and you can get a hybrid you can
get a hybrid corolla for
24 000 bucks i mean so it's good for all
ages and
anybody who's passionate about the
environment and for that awesome price
you also get
the works on the inside let's talk about
the system in here yeah so that middle
console there
um it's a fully touchscreen display it
comes with apple carplay android auto
so all of your apps and everything that
are compatible with your car now show up
there which is super fun and cool
um it also is compatible with alexa so
you could say alexa start my car and
it'll be ready for you go play
for a road trip everyday car as well
absolutely i'm i'm convinced
yeah i'm going hybrid get a hybrid tired
of paying 40
for 200 miles save the world and save
your wallet
all right call findlay automotive in
henderson the number is 702-566-2573 or
you can just visit findlaytoyota.com